just when did animals first walk the
earth nature reports a new study
originating in Poland which takes this
event back a further 20 million years
forcing a revaluation of the most basic
assumptions paleontologists have made
until now
I'm here on the lip of a small quarry in
southern Poland a dog walked this way a
little while ago so you can see the
footprints in here
the dogs long gone we can't see it
anywhere but the prints tell us a great
deal about what size the shape of animal
it was where it was moving to maybe what
he was doing and it's in those
observations that the secret of this
quarry lies because this place has
yielded what I think to be some of the
most exciting fossils I have ever
encountered in my career as a
paleontologist we can see my colleagues
Geragos and piata are looking for more
material over there
fossils of footprints footprints that
give us the earliest record of how our
very distant ancestors moved out of the
water onto the land and took their first
steps on the shores of this planet more
than three hundred and ninety five
million years ago
the thing that's really curious about
this story is the degree to which there
is serendipity behind it and in fact if
I would put it this way we're looking
here the discovery that would only ever
be made in this way somebody Gregor's
went looking for something there to put
footprints as he turns out in a place
where they shouldn't be 20 million years
near enough earlier than we would expect
to find them and kind of in the wrong
environment 2008 I follow this beautiful
specimen with digit impressions I don't
believe that this is a footprint I'm
thinking that this is something
important this is something special
something for better Albert I sent to
him photographs and so I back in May
2009 get this email from Gallegos saying
we've got these prints of what we think
are some kind of lobe-finned fish I have
a look at these pictures we have a
couple of large anatomical footprints
where you can see very obvious
impressions of toes this is footprint of
early tetrapods we have here for example
digits impressions
and something like their pets this is
important
lobe-finned fishes do not have toes they
have fins with big round fin lives the
second thing is that a trackway an
actual series of prints that his scent
shows participants around was going
across the surface now this is the sort
of track that a salamander would leave
if it walks in order to be able to make
the tract it looks like that you need to
have front legs and back legs that are
about the same size in which you can
swing freely back and forth along the
sides of the body we have here small
track way this is not track we made by
fish and phibian like animal this is
track we made by through tetrapod these
tracks are nearly twenty million years
older than the earliest fragmentary
scraps we have of land vertebrates and
30 million years older than the earliest
really decent material so I sat there
and in the course of a single afternoon
found myself revising the entire
understanding ahead of my own field of
research I emailed Gregor's to say look
don't send this to the Polish Journal
you've been thinking about submitting it
to these are not fish tracks the land
vertebrate tracks this is going to be in
the textbooks 50 years from now oh my
word
Oh wonderful look at that
until only a few months ago this was an
accurate model of the kind of animal
paleontologists believed existed in the
middle devonian period with fins but no
proper feet well what can you say I mean
the size is the size is just right isn't
it this is this is the sort of size of
animal we've got to be talking about big
nasty teeth shape of a head in the ice
and that so that's all all that's all
absolutely right but of course what we
need to think about is actual legs with
toes both at the front and in particular
at the back what you actually need is a
great big back leg like this with a big
foot I mean we
you know the toes are gonna be out here
and they're gonna be that big with toes
flexible elbows flexible knees you could
actually walk across the mud flats now
the fish is the graters have been
thinking about which are very close to
the origin of land vertebrates have in
many ways a land animal like body but
what they don't have is legs like that
instead they've got fins at the front
much smaller fins at the back little
tail at the end not in a million years
could you get a body form like this to
make a track of little pairs of prints
going up like this you need for this
quite a different body form what you
actually need is something that looks
like this legs that stick out to the
sides it can flex forwards there it had
to be an animal like this it had to be a
primitive land vertebrate not a fish so
what was the environment like when these
animals first emerged from the water I'm
sitting right now on a surface that
represents a moment in time a single
moment in time or a single day maybe 395
million years ago at the time when these
animals are walking around here this
quarry of course doesn't just contain
the footprints it's also got a record of
the environment in which those
footprints were made and here are some
real surprises considering what we had
previously thought about the origin of
land vertebrates so look at this book
here this is covered in shrimp burrows
this is very typical of marine sediments
we're in the sea here not up in some
River or swamp environment we got
stromatolites these little mounds made
from tiny microscopic algae they grow in
some live shallow seas this is a game of
marine signal all these lumps covering
the entire surface are little
stromatolites
here's the surface covered in
desiccation cracks it shows you not only
that you actually have this surface
emerging out of the water but that it's
doing so for long enough to actually dry
and flake we're in the tropics the land
is very flat the sea and land emerging
you must imperceptibly were in this very
very very shallow sea will the tides
come washing in and out twice a day
we're on on some sort of mud flat under
this baking tropical Sun but of course
if there were today you would have goals
wheeling overhead pelicans that kind of
stuff imagine that world that with
nothing absolutely nothing at all no
mammals and no birds and erectile no
flying insects just out on the mud flats
all you hear is the wind and the waves
and there is nothing in the air and
crawling around or walking around in
very very shallow water out onto the mud
banks backbone animals veterus big
things two and a half three meter long
Vega crocodile like animals with short
stumpy but very robust limbs with short
triangular toes and what are they doing
they're probably picking up washed up
flotsam and jetsam of the tireless left
behind is the tidal zone this happens
twice a day absolutely reliably sea goes
out leaving behind the kind of
smorgasbord of them dead and moribund
animals and almost certainly that's what
these creatures are feeding on look I've
been working personally in this field
since the mid 1980s I have had over 20
publications in nature and this is the
most important paper that I have ever
worked on
I am very pleased to be able to do my
part of this butter tools at heart
this is Travis is great discovery it has
taken us many many great field trips to
this quarry and many months of hard work
you